also ich muss wirklich sagen bis jetzt
jugend die größte rotz seite mal gucken
was a die express dazu sagt immer wenn
ich hier videos drehen also in meinem
alten zimmer ist alles so richtig
unprofessionell man so habe ich
irgendwann mal angefangen aber ich muss
erstmal kurzfilm mit meinem handy leute
hier haben wir die kamera die steht auch
so büchern mit einem stuhl und hier
haben wir mein macbook das ich brauche
das steht auch so kartons und da ist
hoffentlich etwas gedacht und damit
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht
es gut mir auch es ist halt nur
schwierig so die kartons stehen hier
genau vor mir egal ich habe für heute
mal wieder etwas rausgekramt was vor
einem halben jahr wirklich total im
trend war auf einem kanal ist glaube ich
nicht mal ein halbes jahr her aber ich
habe irgendwann damit aufgehört weil ich
sagen glaube ich auch zu viel gemacht
habe und dann auch nicht mehr so bock
drauf hatte und zwar habe es ja
wahrscheinlich schon am titel gelesen
das geht heute um diese online shops you
wish you alibaba express und ich sage
mal so die sind ja vor einem halben jahr
total inhalt bekommen rat auch auf
youtube und auch in deutschland gegen
das make-up meine videos dazu sind auch
ziemlich explodiert und ich denke ich
kenne ich mittlerweile ganz gut damit
aus mit dem versand und so was man
bestellen sollte was eventuell nicht und
ich habe mich letztens einfach mal
gefragt warum ich damit nicht mehr
weiter gemacht habe beziehungsweise
warum ich dass sie noch ein bisschen
cooler auffahren soll wir hatten ja
schon ein handy das wir getestet haben
wir hatten uhren wir hatten smart
switches und so weiter allerdings hat
irgendwie alles nein dann wundert euch
nicht dass es wackelt stative ein
bisschen wackelig war allerdings
irgendwie alles oder nichts von den
juden oder einem anderen online shop
deswegen geht es im heutigen video noch
nicht wirklich darum produkte
auszupacken das gibt es aber dann in den
nächsten wochen extrem gut sagt wir
haben absolut keinen bock mehr drauf
dann schreib das gerne in die kommentare
aber wenn ihr sagt vielleicht noch mal
neu und cooler das dann auf jeden fall
jetzt mal ein viertel nach oben da keine
ahnung ich will es auf jeden fall eine
bewertung sehen wenn wir 8000 leicht
schaffen oder so machen wir auf jeden
fall locker mehrere video einzel sowie
so gehen weil ich habe schon ein paar
sachen bestellt und in diesem video
heute möchte ich einfach mal zusammen
mit euch einkaufen also wir bewegen uns
auf allen drei shops ich habe halt
einmal
ruhig und aliexpress rausgesucht ist
halt alles relativ ähnlich und kaufen
ein für eine menge geld war schauen wie
viel geld ist am ende ist wir fangen
einfach mal angemeldet ist dann schon
verstehen mein ziel ist halt dann in der
zukunft immer öfter videos zu bringen
wie halt wieder sachen angekommen sind
wie zum beispiel einen laptop ich will
heute ein laptop bestellt zum beispiel
oder sonst was man sehen was wir finden
sowie haben wir jetzt einmal express wir
haben hier jugend und erwischt das
kennen wahrscheinlich die meisten von
euch ich möchte natürlich auch ein
bisschen unter den shops vergleichen wie
thorsten handy hier wieder ist ein
stabiler ist der laptop da wie teuer ist
er da genau das erste video was bald
kommen wird ich habe letztens ziemlich
viel bestellt und zwar alles produkte
die kostenlos sind ja mir zum beispiel
sagen wireless charging paket oder so
kopfhörer das hier sieht auch extrem
verstörend aber das habe ich alles schon
bestellt kommen bis zum 21 19 an das
dauert leider immer ein bisschen ich
denke das kommt so anfang september
mitte september alles ich war lange
nicht mehr unterwegs deswegen schauen
wir einfach mal ob es irgendwie was
neues gibt oder so wir werden jetzt
gerade sogar schon laptops angezeigt wir
haben so ein für 34 ach nee das ist ein
ipad pro 50 34 euro wenn ich das jetzt
mal bei jugend eingebe und meinetwegen
hier auch schauen wir mal ob wir da noch
was anderes finden auf alle express gibt
es zum beispiel original ipad und hier
gibt es dann halt nur albert oehlen also
jugend scheint für mich was
elektronische sachen angeht ziemlich
schlecht zu sein
das können wir eigentlich klicken
deswegen würde ich sagen wir nehmen
einfach schon mal hier
das ipad mit ist halt ganz klassisch von
858 euro runtergesetzt auf 34 euro da
hier haben wir einen rabatt von 96 in
gold natürlich ganz wichtig und wir
fügen dass dem wahren koppel sucht jetzt
versuche ich einfach noch einen laptop
rauszuholen für möglichst wenig geld
wobei ich gerade glaube allerdings hat
sich so ein bisschen weiterentwickelt da
gibt es halt auch originale produkte
also hier bekommt man keinen laptop für
unter 100 euro
mal schauen was ruhestand zu sagt ein
laptop wollte ich schon mal bestellen
habe ich dann glaube ich doch nicht
gemacht mal gucken was passiert wenn
mein macbook eingibt ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe jetzt überall
geguckt gibt die teure sachen das ist
mir erst mal zu schade mal gucken was
wir noch zu finden ich habe es gerade
noch dazu diese schule geholt für 10
euro
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal auch
jugendleiter weil
ich habe ich noch gar nicht so viel
gemacht kameras und optik irgendwie
denke ich mir auf dieser seite gibt es
wirklich nur müll
das lohnt sich auch nicht irgendwie
jetzt hier von was zu bestellen ja hier
sind usb-sticks kopfhörer panzer folie
wenn ihr dann tippt dass man da gut
bestellen kann schreibt es auf jeden
fall war jetzt in die kommentare so
generell gesagt also alle sachen die
ankommen möchte ich halt nicht einfach
nur vor der kamera ausparken sondern
wirklich so ein bisschen testen und gut
review ich weiß dass es eigentlich nicht
mein content ist aber man kann seinen
konnten hier anpassen und ich habe auch
lust drauf deswegen warum nicht mal
gucken was wir hier für schuhe kriegen
ich gebe einfach mal oben ein adidas
kommt da irgendwas also das ist wirklich
so eine fake seite da gibt es für 25
euro erwarte ich habe eine gute idee
hochzeitskleid
ich habe schon mal das video gemacht wo
ich hochzeitskleider bestellt habe das
problem war irgendwie ist davon nie 1
angekommen dann habe ich die
bestellungen wieder storniert deswegen
kam es auch nie das video zu jetzt haben
wir aber dieses hochzeit vielleicht
einfach mal mitgenommen für 15 euro wir
haben ihnen laser den ball auch einfach
mal in den einkaufswagen weil damit kann
man nämlich auch das eine oder andere
coole video machen das ist gar keine
schlechte idee
youtube wir bräuchten theoretisch auch
noch für unsere wohnung in köln
fernseher fürs wohnzimmer den würde ich
jetzt einfach mal versuchen auf
aliexpress zugestellt fernseher ja hier
gibt es nur scheiße dann gehen wir mal
rüber zürich gibts nen fernseher 14 euro
und finde ich sehr schade im fernseher
gibt es nirgendwo geht noch mal ein
smart wie vielleicht das ja im fernsehen
gibt es leider nicht wir gehen darüber
in die beliebt kategorie hier sehen wir
sachen die ich schon bestellt haben zum
großen teil 1 euro wo wir haben eine
drohne ist schon für 97 euro
runtergesetzt natürlich von 5000 euro
das ding ist nur ich hab mir selber eine
magic erlebt hier sogar weil wir jetzt
eine magic pro als 100 rollen die
wirklich gute aufnahmen macht die kostet
9200 weit ich weiß ist wenn wir den
jetzt nehmen
für 7 90 euro man könnte das ja
theoretisch einfach mal vergleichen dass
heißt wir nehmen oder ich tue die drohne
jetzt erstmal
in den einkaufswagen hier haben wir eine
fake die l-boxx ja ist halt einfach
stumpf nach gemacht ich habe eine
originale jb l-boxx zu hause das heißt
wir nehmen die einfach mal in schwarz
ich habe die auch in schwarz für 22 euro
die die ich habe waren ein geschenk
kostet neu aber glaube ich so an die 150
und im ist natürlich ein unterschied da
kann man jetzt schon ist es eventuell
nur die marke ist so teuer macht oder
ist die originalversion wirklich um
klassen besser als diese b 2050
waterproof sind wasserfest für 22 euro
da kann man echt nich meckern wenn wir
auch gleich mal im vergleich gucken
musikbox hier auf juden kriegt man
wieder keine da gibt es dann irgendwie
eine nähmaschine
also ich muss wirklich sagen bis jetzt
jugend die größte rott seite mal gucken
was aliexpress dazu sagt die haben dann
einfach mal eine schatzkiste im angebot
ist eigentlich schade also ich mach dir
schon das rennen was sie auch krass fand
ein paar wirklich gute fußballer haben
für werbung immer also bei denen muss
wirklich laufen liegt auch
wahrscheinlich zum teil dann an meinen
videos natürlich damals produziert
hatten wir schon mal weiter was sind
zwar noch hierbei beliebt ohne die für
frauen ja hier haben wir schuhe
ich würde mal sagen ein bisschen
angelehnt an louis vitton könnte man
schon so sehen schon mal dieses smart
watch habe ich sogar noch genau hier
liegen ja fast die gleiche hatte ich
glaube ich damals für 19 euro gekauft
kann aber einiges hier haben wir eine
drohne für 26 euro
ok 50 euro ich würde sagen wir tun die
einfach rein und löschen die andere nach
für mich auch mehr sinn hier ist die box
für 18 euro und jetzt wahrscheinlich
auch für 20
na gut kommt nehmen wir doch einfach die
haben wir zwei euro gespart für den
garten für 10 euro hinweis natürlich
haben wir auch einmal vielleicht hier
eine drohne haben die sowas ja die haben
dann die originalen sachen ich finde
wirklich obwohl hier hätten wir eine
drohne für 15 dollar
doch nicht 15 dollar 64 dollar also
leute wir hatten jetzt hier im einkauf
sagen ein paar produkte werden insgesamt
bei 300 löschen also ich würde einfach
mal sagen ihr kommentiert ganz fleißig
in den kommentaren
wo auch sonst was ihr produkt speziell
bestellen soll ich will jetzt nicht dass
hier
video 20 minuten geht das sollte
eigentlich nur ein kleiner vorgeschmack
sein was in zukunft halt euch auf diesem
kanal wieder erwartet also ich habe
einfach lust drauf einiges habe ich ja
schon bestellt einiges werde ich auch
noch bestellen schreibt auch gerne
weitere shops in die kommentare wo man
gut was bestellen kann außerdem die ich
euch jetzt halt schon gezeigt habe hier
und dann bin ich einfach mal gespannt
auf die kostenlosen sachen die welt
ankommen werden ich bin gespannt auf das
ipad ich bin ich bei noch die schuhe auf
die drohende keine ahnung und vielleicht
lässt sich ja noch das eine oder andere
coole produkt wirklich finden das nicht
vom hocker haut das ist das ziel für die
video sonde ich hoffe dieses wir heute
euch gefallen
wir bestellen das jetzt alles und das
wird wahrscheinlich so mitte september
an kommen hier haben wir im warenkorb
auch noch zwei sachen genau einmal den
laser und das hochzeitskleid das gute
ist hier ist der versand sogar kostenlos
und es kommt schneller an also das wäre
meiner meinung nach dann der einzige
pluspunkt der im juni
ich freue mich so auf abonniert auf
jeden fall den kanal um davon nicht zu
verpassen wird cool kann ich darüber
sprechen und wir sehen uns wieder rein